Steve McQueen
you charge everything you fashion with
the breath of your own spirit
thank you so much for putting me in this
position
it has been the joy of my life
to Hotel thank you for your fearlessness
and How Deeply you went into selling
Solomon's story Michael Fassbender thank
you so much you were my rock Alfrey and
Sarah it was a thrill to work with you I
want to thank my family for your
training
and the Yale School of drama as well for
your training my brother junior is
sitting by my side thank you so much
when I look down at this golden statue
may it remind me and every little child
that no matter where you're from your
dreams are valid thank you thank you